top dork right here right the super
dork is we we we have to fight to keep
do even if even if even if eventually it
becomes outdated like why do we have
physical dollars it's really important
another thing too that they're trying to
get rid of the penny right the phys you
know just pennies right no one really
uses them anymore but the reason they're
important is because if you get rid of
the penny the what's the next one the 5
cents so when they start increasing
prices they start increasing it by 5
Cent at a time and if you get rid let
imagine they get rid of all the they
keep quarters so that means what'll
happen is whatever the lowest nomination
well that's the only thing we can
increase it by so we just do this so
what'll happen is if you get rid of the
penny and you get rid of the 5 cents and
the dimes and you just go to quarters
you'll start having prices start jumping
up crazy you're admitting that it's
worthless exactly